the walking dead has killed off dozens
of characters over the course of its run
but
not all of those deaths have been
satisfying we're here to take a look at
the walking dead's most moving and
meaningful character endings as well as
the most
frustrating and cheap whenever a new
character gets a little extra screen
time
savvy audiences know to start preparing
for a dramatic death
denise cloyd is a perfect example
introduced as one of the townspeople in
alexandria she reluctantly becomes the
community's doctor
when denise sets off on a supply mission
with daryl and rosita in the sixth
season
her modest arc kicks suddenly into high
gear denise is determined to become the
sort of person tara her girlfriend
deserves
after risking her life to get an orange
soda denise is lectured by the others
she starts to explain what this trip
really means to her revealing that daryl
reminds her of her brave brother and
that
lonely rosita reminds her of who she
used to be suddenly she
shot through the eye with a bolt from
daryl's stolen crossbow now wielded
by dwight this moment feels like a hasty
end to a relatively inconsequential
character
designed to ramp up alexandria's
impending war with the saviors
the walking dead has proven time and
again that it can wrap up season-long
arcs without shameless shock moments
like this the minute she starts taking
up more screen time
you pretty much know she's headed for
the grave before the credits roll
you're my first patient and with that
symptom
i'm pretty sure i can't kill you simon
is a character who seems largely
inconsequential right up until the
moment he single-handedly loses the war
for the saviors
for most of his run this psychopath who
acts as negan's right-hand man
remains on his master's leash the show
takes
full advantage of steven ogg's acting
chops whenever they need someone to
demonstrate
what loose cannons the saviors can be
hey you like ice cream we have ice cream
subtle signs of a power struggle between
him and negan emerges the series winds
on which comes to a head after negan's
apparent
death simon makes good on his promise to
lead the group in a different way
which values wiping out the savior's
enemies rather than converting them
however when negan returns simon finally
reaches the end of his rope
and decides to stage a coup simon is
foiled by double agent dwight
negan stops the underhanded takeover and
challenges simon to a one-on-one fist
fight to the death simon lands a few
cheap shots before he's ultimately
strangled to death by negan in one of
the show's most
thrilling sequences this moment proves
negan's formidable reputation
is well earned closes out a fascinating
character arc
and brings an elegant end to one of the
most intriguing power struggles in the
show's history
t-dog never really gets his time to
shine sure
he has some of the snarkiest lines of
the early seasons and he definitely
brings some much-needed blunt wisdom to
the group but by and large
t-dog is just a background character the
show fails to do anything interesting
with
tdog meets his end in the middle of
season 3 when the prison becomes overrun
with walkers
he and carol find themselves in the
unfortunate position of having to
reclose the gates
in the man he gets bitten on the
shoulder which ensures his doom
he spends the remainder of his life
rambling about god's plan for him
in the end he charges two walkers and
allows himself to be devoured
so that carol can escape tdog's death
makes
the moment tense but even that effect is
muddled by the fact that laurie a
significantly more consequential
character
dies in the same fray making the loss of
another day one character like t-dog
just
plain redundant his heroic sacrifice and
newfound faith in the lord
feels less like the completion of a
character arc and more like a shoehorned
ending created for shock value
but i'm the one black guy realize how
precarious that makes my situation
glenn meets his end after daryl punches
negan prompting the villain to randomly
select glenn to murder
the moment is violent and gruesome as
glenn chokes out his last words to his
wife who can't
bear the sight of his grotesquely beaten
visage
the characters and audience watch
helplessly as a character who's been
around a whole lot longer than most
is brought to a bitter bloody end while
the show's worst deaths peel hollow
glen's death is heavy with actual
meaning
negan is not an easily solvable problem
and thus
his death is not there to distract from
this fact as
so many lesser deaths are in the wake of
his death it once again feels like
no one is truly safe unlike other deaths
glenn's demise isn't signaled with
shoehorned dialogue or a sudden
significant moment of calm
he dies at the height of his life with a
new safe haven to call home and a wife
who's about to give birth to their first
child this moment sends a clear message
that the show
will never be the same
people you love
they made you who you are they're still
part of you
the reason that jesus's death remains
one of the walking dead's worst
character endings has a lot to do with
the fact that his comic
book counterpart is so much better on
the page
jesus is a capable fighter and as actor
tom payne noted in an interview with the
hollywood reporter he spent all his time
training for fight scenes that never
actually came
jesus is a big part of the war against
the saviors in the comics his death is
supposed to draw audiences
into a scary new plot featuring a
powerful threat but
all it does is disappoint in what ends
up being the only scene showing what
fans wanted from jesus
he uses his sword to take down multiple
walkers in one of the most well done
action sequences on the show then it all
ends with him taking a swipe at a walker
only to discover the walker is actually
a member of the newly discovered
whisperer faction
wearing a disguise while this is a cool
way to introduce a villain
it's a lame ending for a character who
should have been the coolest thing to
hit the walking dead since the arrival
of negan
no matter what they've done they're
people
there's many kinds of danger many kinds
of dying
no ending on the walking dead embodies
the series blend of tension
horror and emotion more than moral
dixons after making a splash in just
two episodes of the show back in season
one merle comes back in a big way in
season three as one of the governor's
right-hand men
however once his baby brother daryl is
back in the equation
it becomes clear that merle does in fact
have an odd sense of loyalty
eventually he chooses daryl over the
governor but is frustrated to find that
his little bro
isn't interested in choosing him over
rick in an effort to prove that he's the
only one with the guts to do what's
necessary in this new world
merle goes rogue and takes his very own
shot at the governor
unfortunately it doesn't work out though
merle manages to take out a large number
of the villain's men
he's quickly overwhelmed killed and left
to turn
this brings an end to his character arc
and brutally proves that he was wrong
all along daryl finds his undead brother
and puts him down in a cathartic display
of anger
showing that the dixon brothers are by
far the most complicated characters on
the show
you need to grow up things different now
one glaring issue with abraham's death
is that it's
shamelessly milked as a cliffhanger
season six concludes with negan's
infamous introduction
an agonizing six months of speculation
among fans followed
at last the show returned and it was
revealed that the biggest guy in the
group who
isn't main character rick grimes is the
one negan decides to take off the board
seeing a member of the group who is so
tough and has survived so much be
violently killed while his friends are
helpless to do anything about it
is hard to stomach however all that
tension and purpose gets thrown out the
window
when in the season seven premiere negan
murders glenn in the exact same way
glenn had been around since the second
episode of the series he has a wife
pregnant with her first child who is
forced to watch as he is unceremoniously
beaten to death
glenn's death might very well be the
most gut-wrenching demise on an
already bloody show abraham should not
have shared the spotlight with him at
that pivotal moment
despite the character arc that this
death at negan's hands brings to a close
he'll forever be remembered as the guy
who dies before glenn
while some of the best character endings
come as the result of an impactful story
coming to a worthwhile close
others make the list simply because it's
fun to see an incredibly evil character
go down
for two long seasons beta acts as a
leader of the whisperers while carrying
out
ruthless attacks although he pays
deferrings to alpha and follows her with
almost dog-like loyalty
her death does not put a stop to his
wicked ways he carries out her legacy by
unleashing a horde of zombies
on some of the only remaining
non-whisperer human beings in the area
after making life a living hell for our
heroes for several years
beta finally bites off more than he can
chew when he leads his horde against
daryl and negan
after losing what's left of his mind at
the sight of negan the man who killed
alpha
beta throws a walker on him before
slamming him onto the ground
several times just when it looks like
it's lights out for negan
daryl swoops in and jams two knives into
beta's eyes
he is then killed by the very walkers
who gave him protection all these awful
years
if that's not a satisfying end to a
villain we don't know what
is ending on the show it is important to
note that his ending hasn't
actually happened yet but he's off the
franchise temporarily
the season 9 episode what comes after
serves as an
hour-long goodbye to the walking dead's
main character unfortunately
it doesn't make a ton of sense in his
ongoing effort to unite the groups he
now leads after the war with negan
rick is wounded while desperately trying
to lead a herd away from the living
bleeding out and driven only by his
desire to save the people he loves he
continues to lure walker's way
as he hallucinates some of the most
emotional moments of his life
curiously absent from his poignant
hallucinations however
are his recently deceased son his very
much alive daughter
and his long deceased wife laurie those
odd absences aren't the only weird
things about the episode
the entire episode plays out like a
colossal victory lap for the character
but it's unclear exactly what the
victory is
his people are far from safe in fact
they're more divided and in need of
leadership than ever
his son has recently died in the war
whose fallout he is still trying to fix
despite the heroes ending he gets by
blowing up a bridge of walkers
rick doesn't exactly leave the series on
a high note
it's a triumphal exit the show simply
doesn't earn
i'm not the good guy anymore
when sasha first arrives in season 3 the
show spends a lot of time not quite
knowing what to do with her her life
takes a major turn when she begins to
develop feelings for abraham
unfortunately their romance is cut short
by abraham's death
similar to maggie sasha spends what is
left of her life enmeshed in the war
with the saviors
seeking revenge unlike maggie sasha
isn't pregnant and is thus able to
really inflict some damage
she and rosita embark on an
assassination mission
before they're separated sasha pays
tribute to her late love interest by
remarking that negan denied him the
honor of going out fighting
sadly her assassination attempt fails
off-screen
she's captured and negan makes it clear
that he plans to use her to get
alexandria to surrender
locked in a cell disarmed and having had
all hope removed
sasha still manages to hatch a pretty
stellar plan
she convinces eugene to give her a
suicide pill so that when negan makes
his big reveal of having taken her as a
prisoner she can attack him as a walker
in front of all of alexandria
although she fails to exact the revenge
she sought
she still manages to honor abraham by
going out fighting
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one